a la mecque une ambassade américaine
attaqué au pakistan manifestation
monstre à téhéran
l'islam en ébullition une lettre de
valéry giscard d'estaing à raymond barre
elle définit l'action du gouvernement
pour les six prochains mois
là messieurs bonsoir l'islam en
effervescence on ne peut pas vraiment
parler d'un embrasement car le mot est
un peu fort mais disons que depuis
quelques heures une série de foyers se
sont allumées sans qu'il soit possible à
cette heure précise de vous dire de
quelle façon
l' incendie va se propager avant de
rentrer dans le détail gratte me grâce à
notre réseau de correspondants et
envoyés spéciaux dans le monde entier je
voudrais brièvement résumée à un coup de
force en arabie saoudite dans la grande
mosquée de la mecque le lieu le plus
sacré de l'islam
l'endroit que chaque musulman rêve de
visiter au moins une fois dans sa vie
deux incendies de l'ambassade américaine
à islamabad c'est-à-dire au pakistan
pays lui aussi à majorité très largement
musulmane
l'ambassade est ce soir complètement
détruite mais ses occupants à
l'exception d'un seul sont sains et
saufs
enfin et toujours la situation
véritablement dramatique des otages de
l'ambassade américaine de téhéran
ballotté entre les décisions
contradictoires de l'ayatollah khomeini
de son ministre bani sadr et des
étudiants qui les retiennent prisonnier
d'abord donc la mecque une situation ce
soir encore très confuse
il n'est toujours pas possible de vous
dire avec précision qui a investi la
grande mosquée apparemment des musulmans
chiites minoritaires en arabie saoudite
pas plus que de vous dire si oui ou non
tous les otages ont pu être libérés
le ministère de l'intérieur saoudien se
contentant de dire qui le contrôlent la
situation
la mecque c'est le but que chaque
musulman se doit d'atteindre une fois au
moins dans sa vie
l'islam l'imposent ils sont aujourd'hui
plusieurs millions à s'y rendre
hier plusieurs centaines de pèlerins se
trouvaient dans l'enceinte de la grande
mosquée lorsqu'un commando armé les ja
retenus otages
aucun communiqué officiel n'est venu le
confirmer mais il semble cependant qu'un
premier assaut donné aujourd'hui en fin
de matinée par les forces de sécurité
saoudiennes et permis de libérer un
grand nombre de ses fidèles
on pense en revanche que tous les hommes
en armes
retranchés à l'intérieur de la mosquée
n'ont pas été expulsés et que d'autres
pèlerins reste prisonnier à la mecque
l'endroit où les pèlerins du monde
entier se tiennent debout devant dieu la
moindre entorse au rite est une faute
grave il n'est pas étonnant dans ces
conditions que le communiqué officiel du
ministre saoudien de l'intérieur par le
des auteurs de cette prise d'otages
comme d'un groupe d'hérétique
on ignore tout des motivations de ce
commando on a seulement appris qu'hier
après avoir refermé les portes de la
mosquée sur les otages l'un des
assaillants a exigé d'être reconnu comme
le nouveau prophète le mahdi c'est le
nom que l'on donne dans l'islam à celui
qui sera chargé de poursuivre l'oeuvre
de mahomet apparemment il ne semble pas
que les assaillants soient nus par des
raisons de politique intérieure il ne
serait pas non plus téléguidé par l'iran
puisque l'ayatollah khomeiny a condamné
ce geste
ce serait donc plutôt des chiites qui je
voulais dire présente une très petite
minorité de la population saoudienne
environ cent à cent cinquante mille
personnes sur huit millions apparemment
nous le disions les autorités dorian ne
veulent pas dramatiser le prince fahd
c'est à dire le prince héritier du trône
a même ostensiblement choisi de rester à
tunis au sommet des paysages alors
pourquoi est ce que nous donnons tout
d'importance à cette affaire est bien
parce que l'arabie saoudite occupe
vraiment une position plus dans cette
région du monde
c'est le premier fournisseur de
l'occident en pétrole et c'était jusqu'à
lors le pays politiquement et
économiquement le plus stable de cette
zone d'ouvrières
l'arabie saoudite depuis toujours par
son histoire le premier lieu saint du
monde de l'islam mais devenu aussi
depuis une dizaine d'années le dernier
bastion du monde occidental
à commencer par sa position géographique
face au régime
eux aussi islamique mais ici franchement
hostile aux américains pakistan irak est
aujourd'hui iran dernier bastion du
monde occidental par intérêt l'arabie
saoudite premier producteur mondial de
pétrole
devenu peu à peu le premier exportateur
de ce pétrole notamment vers l'occident
et il faut bien savoir qu'aujourd'hui le
quart des importations totales de
pétrole du monde occidental provient de
ce seul pays
l'arabie saoudite les dirigeants
saoudiens auront même été un peu plus
loin au lendemain de la baisse de la
production pétrolière de l'iran ils ont
décidé d'augmenter leur propre
production pour atteindre aujourd'hui 9
million et demi de barils par jour un
million de plus que le niveau normal les
compensations du monde occidental
principalement des états unis sont à la
hauteur
les 8 millions de saoudiens vivent à
l'heure américaine y compris une armée
de 60 mille hommes entièrement
conseiller équipés par washington
bien entendu pour compenser la perte de
l'iran paradoxe en fin d'un régime qu
apporte son soutien politique et
financier à tous les pays opposés à
israël qui aura même été jusqu'à rompre
ses relations diplomatiques avec
l'egypte
mais qui reste aujourd'hui encore le
plus modéré des pays producteurs de
pétrole où il n'est pas question de
remettre en cause ses relations avec
washington sans pour autant décevoir les
régimes les plus durs de l'islam et avec
en main ce que tous considèrent
aujourd'hui comme l' arme la plus
redoutable
le pétrole et l'occident a d'autant plus
tendu l'oreille que dans le même temps
éclaté je vous le disais un autre foyer
d'incendié au pakistan très précisément
à islamabad la capitale où ce matin à la
foule
et ce n'est pas une coïncidence a
encerclé et attaqué l'ambassade
américaine
l'armée pakistanaise est aussitôt
intervenue mais l'affrontement a été
rude
un marine américain est mort et les
bâtiments ont été entièrement détruits
dès que des images nous arrive de là bas
vous les verrez bien sûr on assiste
également à des incidents à karachi et
aussi à rawalpindi où ce sont là des
locaux britanniques ceux du centre
culturel qui ont été attaqués le
président pakistanais a présenté ses
excuses au gouvernement américain et
anglais
et puis je vous le disais dans le même
temps presque simultanément une
manifestation monstre réunissait à
téhéran près d'un millions d'iraniens
autour de l'ambassade des états unis où
je vous laisse imaginer l'incroyable
isolement des otages sans aucune
nouvelle sur leur sort alors pourquoi
cette manifestation est bien pour
célébrer l'avènement du 15e siècle de
l'hégire c'est-à-dire de l'ère musulmane
dans les rues de téhéran
répondant à l'appel de l'ayatollah
khomeini fois différent de l'aisne les
cortèges ont convergé vers l'ambassade
américaine au cri d' allah est grand
rouge de laura car tel était le premier
depuis le départ du shah
l'an passé l'armée avait tiré dans la
foule qui est à elle à l'empereur
cette année deux iraniens et des
mortiers la lutte anti américaine était
de bois il sert park est à leurs côtés
cette fantastique démonstration de force
et de suka poster à l'ayatollah khomeini
attendus seront très vigilants
islamistes il aime les otages devaient
s'imposer pour menacer de les exécuter
ils états unis intervenait pour les
libérer la prise d'otage de la mecque a
eu que des gosses qui à téhéran pendant
cette manifestation est là plutôt
surpris par sa violence et a rappelé
l'ayatollah khomeiny a cru préférable de
la condamnée et j'ajoute que la
délégation iranienne qui voulaient
accéder au sommet arabe a été refoulée
par les services de sécurité à tunis
voilà malgré le démenti de monsieur
banny ça dans le responsable iranien des
affaires étrangères qui ne pense pas que
le procès des otages aura lieu à la
mairie qu'un s'inquiète bien sûr et ont
décidé d'envoyer dans l'océan indien
l'un de leurs plus gros porte-avions le
kitty hawk à lui seul il peut
transporter 85 avions et 5000 hommes
mais il ne viendra pas seul le midway
l'escortera à eux deux ces bâtiments
représentent 3 base aérienne française
la plus votre foi la pression interne
avec solennité la classe b de fret une
pression militaire à l'énergie
et voilà maintenant que les étudiants
islamiques de peyrens menace d'exécuter
immédiatement leurs otages si les
intentions américaines intervention se
précise trop nettement alors devant
cette accélération fantastique des
événements depuis quelques heures il
faut essayer de garder la tête froide et
de prendre avec paul nahon quelques
reculs
quant aux conséquences possibles je
crois qu'il est très difficile de faire
des hypothèses sur l'évolution de la
situation pour la raison essentielle que
tout ce qui se passe en ce moment dans
cette région clé n'obéit plus aux règles
internationales en vigueur et que les
schémas classiques prévus en cas de
crise eh bien tous ces schémas ne sont
plus applicables
aujourd'hui désormais plus personne ne
peut prévoir ce qui va arriver dans les
jours qui viennent
en tout cas l'exemple iranien de
conséquences immédiates il fait tache
d'huile dans le reste du monde islamique
avec une vitesse absolument incroyable
le pakistan l'arabie saoudite et viser
d'autres pays islamiques
avec pourtant des régimes modérés
craignent désormais la contagion
deuxième conséquence il faut constater
que c'est au moment précis où la
puissance américain est la plus faible
la plus atteinte dans le monde que les
intérêts américains que ses intérêts
sont attaqués mais pour la première fois
depuis le début de la crise iranienne
la maison blanche a parlé d'actions
militaires concrètes pour libérer les
otages cependant comment aujourd'hui
l'exécutif américain
pourrait-il prendre une telle décision
sans remettre en jeu tous l'equilibre
mondiale quoi qu'il en soit à travers ce
fanatisme religieux à travers ces actes
de terrorisme absolument sans précédent
c'est la cohésion apparente du monde
occidental qui est visé heyer si le
pétrole était liée à la stabilité de ce
monde occidental
aujourd'hui pour maintenir sa stabilité
le mot guerre apparaît malheureusement
comme une hypothèse de plus en plus
probable oui la guerre qui sera le thé
de notre prochain question de temps
lundi soir tout de suite après le
journal une réaction française ce matin
aux événements d'iran celle du conseil
des ministres la france a pour principe
de respecter la dépendance des états
mais les règles qui régissent les
immunités diplomatiques et qui sont
conformes aux droits universels s'impose
à tous en toute circonstance quelle que
soit l'émotion ressentie par le peuple
iranien poursuit le communiqué l'elysée
aucun motif ne saurait justifier que
l'on s'empare de l'ambassade et que l'on
traite son personnel en otage
l'iran l'un des sujets qui sera
forcément abordé par le présent la
république au milieu de dossiers de
politique intérieure et autres au cours
de l'entretien qu'il accordera sur
antenne 2 mardi prochain à 20 heures
avec jean piat que la bâche genre et
gérard saint paul et alain duhamel ce
sera donc dans le cadre de l'émission
une heure avec le président de la
république pour conséquence ce journal
sera avancé mardi 28 il commencera à
19h30 et les dossiers de l'écran seront
diffusés à partir de 21h donc mardi
prochain
en attendant une première indication sur
les choix du président pour les mois à
venir la lettre qu'il a adressée
aujourd'hui à raymond barre et qui lui
fixe les objectifs du gouvernement pour
les six prochains mois nos copains à
matignon la démarche du président de la
république n'est pourtant pas nouvelle
elle date de janvier 1975 et il ne faut
pas croire que la présence à matignon
serait une sorte de bail renouvelable
tous les semestres
mais aujourd'hui les journalistes et les
hommes politiques qui vont lire ce texte
vont remarquer à l'avant dernier
paragraphe
ces trois petits mots sous votre
autorité
eh bien je pense que ces trois petits
mots pourrait bien être la confirmation
attendue
ajoutez à cela que le président de la
république exprime sa satisfaction
les engagements pris il ya six mois ont
été tenues et des progrès ont été
accomplis mais surtout les grandes
orientations définies aujourd'hui pour
les six mois à venir s'inscrivent dans
la continuité
premier objectif améliorer la vie
quotidienne des français cela concerne
la famille la protection de l'enfance
l'assurance des veuves la protection
contre la violence l'environnement
culturel et surtout bien sûr l'emploi
qui demeure prioritaire deuxième
objectif la préparation de la france à
son avenir
notamment dans le cadre du 8ème plan là
c'est l'indépendance énergétique de la
france qui est la priorité le président
insiste également sur le développement
de la recherche scientifique et sur
l'innovation technologique
il s'agit on le voit de poursuivre de
continuer ce qui permet de penser que
c'est raymond barre qui continuera
politique toujours à l'assemblée le
débat sur la politique familiale prendra
fin demain soir c'est à ce moment là que
nous le résumeront la famille est une
priorité nationale a déclaré madame
pelletier une précision du ministre de
l'industrie andré giraud pendant le
conseil des ministres dont nous parlions
le nucléaire qui fournit aujourd'hui 15%
de l'électricité française en fournira
dans six ans c'est à dire en 85 56 %
et puis ce sondage de paris match et de
public jusqu'à rocard 50 50 au second
tour giscard mitterrand 52/48 jusqu'à
marché 66 34
mais pour le premier tour et pour la
première fois michel rocard devancerait
d'un point valéry giscard d'estaing 36
françois mitterrand lui serait distancé
30 40
enfin bernard pons à antenne 2 me dit
tout à l'heure il y a eu de tout temps
des convergences entre les aspirations
gaulliste et socialiste bernard pons qui
par ailleurs s'en est pris à raymond
barre
nous les écouter les propos tenus par
monsieur bart au nom du gouvernement
alors ça c'était d'une certaine violence
et j'ai d'ailleurs dit que c'étaient les
faibles qui s'exprimait ainsi c'est
parce que pour le ministre ce sens un
petit peu faible et parce que il est un
petit peu désemparé devant les résultats
de son action politique
hier soir hier après-midi dans le débat
à l'assemblée nationale j'ai entendu
monsieur chine au président du groupe
udf à l'assemblée nationale se tourner
vers nous et dire mes chers amis
venaient vers nous et parlons ça n'était
pas du tout le même langage que tenait
monsieur bart alors je voudrais que
entre le gouvernement et
la formation de la majorité qui le
soutient du manière inconditionnelle
il ya d'abord devant une certaine
coordination et s'il en est ainsi nous
sommes prêts à parler mais il faudrait
pas que monsieur bart premier ministre
devienne le premier dénominateur des
difficultés qui interviennent à l'heure
actuelle au niveau de la majorité
suspension très provisoire aujourd'hui
de la grève des contrôleurs aériens
fonds vient d'apprendre à l'instant dans
une dépêche
qu'on me tant que la grève devrait
reprendre car tout l'après-midi
syndicats et direction ont négocié sur
d'ultimes base mais la réunion viennent
à l'instant de s'achever sur un échec
donc reprise très probable de la grève à
partir de demain où d'après nos une
solution peut être en vue en revanche
chez alstom atlantique le ministre du
travail jean matteoli a envoyé aux
parties concernées ses recommandations
pour mettre fin à ce conflit monsieur
salmon les lui avait transmises elles
prennent en compte une partie des
revendications syndicales la direction
d'alstom atlantique a d'ores et déjà
accepté ce plan on attend maintenant la
réponse des syndicats
un conflit au point mort celui de nice
matin à paris aujourd'hui plus de 200
ouvriers du livre ont occupé pendant une
bonne partie de la journée les locaux du
syndicat national de la presse régionale
toujours pas de journal demain donc sur
la côte d'azur et en corse
le chef de l'état a reçu aujourd'hui à
l'elysée plus de 200 travailleurs
immigrés sceptre rencontre entre dans le
cadre de la semaine du dialogue organisé
par lionel stoléru le but de cette
semaine étant de favoriser les échanges
entre les 4 millions d'immigrés et les
50 millions de français
mesdames messieurs notre réunion ce soir
confirme l'engagement de la france et
mon engagement personnel de réaliser
concrètement sur notre sol l'égalité des
droits de lutter contre toute forme de
racisme d'éliminer toute forme de
discrimination de donner à toutes les
familles étrangères vivant en france le
maximum de sécurité compatible avec la
situation actuelle est de faire accepter
et reconnaître partouche le droit
légitime à l'identité et à la différence
culturelle en assurant l'égalité en
développant la fraternité nous
abolissons ainsi les barrières pour que
les travailleurs immigrés et leurs
familles se sentent chez eux en france
via un journal on y tient peut-être à
faire tomber certaines de ces barrières
un bimensuel sans frontières sans
frontières est entièrement réalisé par
des immigrés donc pour les immigrés les
difficultés financières de la sécurité
sociale ont des retombées a prévu sur
certains français déjà défavorisées les
personnes âgées qui reçoivent une aide
de ménagère à domicile près de 300 mille
retraités reçoit cette aide
ils ont en moyenne 80 ans et leurs
revenus sont faibles
l'aide ménagère à domicile leur est
imparti payé par l'aide sociale ou par
la sécurité sociale en tout cas c'est la
solution qu'ils préfèrent car il
souhaite presque tous restés chez eux
or plusieurs d'entre eux voient ces
jours ci le financement de cette aide
mise en cause en particulier dans la
région rhône alpes et à paris ils sont
quinze ans dans le xviiie arrondissement
à recevoir une aide ménagère à domicile
ce sont les plus vieux les plus les plus
démunis
récemment plusieurs d'entre eux ont reçu
de très mauvaises nouvelles j'ai le
regret de vous informer que conformément
à la décision de chant conseil
d'administration la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie à la de la légion un
billet
ne participe lui à l'affichage des fêtes
aide ménagère à domicile
ça veut dire que vous n'avez plus le
droit à une aide ménagère mais
n'achètent que j'aime plus loin et
ménagers jusque là vous êtes responsable
d'une association qui envoient des aides
ménagères aux personnes âgées
comment s'est passée cette réduction de
fond bien oui responsable d'une
association dans le xviiie
arrondissement de paris nous avons été
alertés sous forme verbale j'insiste aux
alentours du mois de mai qui avaient des
problèmes de crime j'ai la caisse
maladie et que les aides ménagères
risquaient d'être les premières victimes
de ces insuffisances de crédit et puis
ensuite vous avez une confirmation
nous avons une confirmation écrite toute
récente à la suite du conseil
d'administration de la caisse du 21
septembre
les personnes âgées viennent seulement
de recevoir cette notification écrite
combien de personnes sont concernées
alors sur 15 cents personnes âgées dans
notre propre arrondissement du xviiie
nous avons quarante deux personnes âgées
donc victime de ce désengagement sur le
plan de l'île de france ça représente
déjà des chiffres plus importants bien
sur 350 environ sur paris et un millier
sur l'île de france le problème de paris
c'est une brèche qui atteint voyez
encore des effectifs plus importants
mais c'est une brèche sérieuse
une mise en cause de service pour des
personnes comme celle ci complètement
invalides l'aide-ménagère fait tout
courses ménage soit personne fort cela
sans cette aide qui coûtent 30 francs
par jour les seuls recours sont la
maison de retraite de 100 francs ou
l'hôpital 590 francs par jour économie
bien douteuse avec en prime la tristesse
d'un vieillard obligé de quitter son
domicile
si vous faites vos courses ou 20 par
mois chez valve mnhn
vous sortez de votre appartement
quelques fois depuis combien de temps
8ème pour vous cette lettre qu'est ce
que ça représente s'appelle que si les
noms mais on va le ménager
évidemment c'est très grave et est toute
la question est de savoir si cette
rupture de financement est définitive et
silva s'étend à de nouveaux retraités et
bien c'est la question que l'on osera
fin donc posé tout à l'heure à daniel
hoeffel socoda d'état à l'action sociale
les personnes âgées qui ont un revenu
mensuel inférieur à tous en france
voient leur aide ménagère prise en
charge par l'aide sociale
pour elle aucune restriction
c'est une dépense obligatoire aucune
limitation n'est intervenu pour les
personnes âgées dont le revenu mensuel
départ ces douces en france vous voulez
la prise en charge de l'aide ménagère se
fait à travers la caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse ou les régimes de
retraites complémentaires comme l'aide
ménagère a connu des progrès
considérables au cours des dernières
années puisque nous l'avons doublé en
trois ans les dotations qui ont été
dégagés par ces caisses de retraite se
sont trouvés dans certaines régions
épuisés en fin d'année mais des
dotations complémentaires seront dégagés
afin de permettre la rue
cette aide ménagère avec le brouillard
et les premiers froids la grippe fait sa
réapparition et la france ferme ses
frontières au moins moralement on
regarde du côté du texas où l'urss qui
nous ont agressés l'an dernier on
regarde du côté de hong kong et on
fouille même le fond des âges pour
découvrir l'intrus dans le monde entier
un réseau de surveillance de la grippe
est installé pour capter au plus vite un
éventuel nouveau coupable et l'on
commence à contrôler de très près
certains animaux suspects d'être des
réservoirs de virus grippaux martin à
agneaux et allait le club professeur
hanoune de la cie du pasteur enquêteurs
à sal l'action se passe dans la camargue
du nord cette magnifique baie de somme
ou sur des milliers d'hectares les
oiseaux migrateurs sauvages sont croisés
liban libre ils le sont vraiment
totalement sauf quelques minutes ce jour
là sous les auspices du muséum
d'histoire naturelle des ornithologues
sont allés au petit matin en capturer
quelques les oiseaux venus s'abriter
dans la réserve de marck en terre entre
deux voyages pour l'afrique l'asie ou
l'amérique
normalement le travail se borne à
recenser les oiseaux mais cette fois on
va profiter de cette capture est clair
pour repérer quelles sortes de virus les
migrateurs peuvent propager au tour du
monde
on sait que les oiseaux migrateurs et en
particulier les canards sont souvent
porteurs de virus de la grippe sont
porteurs dans la gorge et aussi dans
l'intestin et de nombreuses souches de
virus ont été isolés dans plusieurs pays
depuis trois ans nous faisons ces
recherches en france sur les oiseaux
comme nous les faisons aussi sur
d'autres espèces animales
par exemple on fait souvent des
prélèvements chez les chez les porcs
qu'est ce que vous faites exactement
alors chez les oiseaux nous cherchons à
trouvez les virus dont ces animaux sont
porteurs et les virus qu'ils hébergent
sont des virus qui leur sont propres qui
sont des virus de grippe d'oiseaux et
quelquefois ce sont des virus qui sent
qu'ils ont des traits communs qui ont
des antigènes commun avec les virus
humains
c'est à dire que il y à toute une
famille de virus de la grippe les uns
qu'on trouve chez les oiseaux les autres
qu'on trouve chez l'homme mais on peut
assister à des franchissements de
barrière d'espèce les russes de la bible
de l'homme peuvent se trouver chez les
oiseaux rituel oblige
l'identification d'abord on mesure lel
qui dira l'âge ont bac où on contrôle la
bague pour savoir qui est le migrant
d'où il vient et c'est alors seulement
que va se faire en quelques secondes sur
un simple bout de coton le prélèvement
vivre ça c'est une femelle
qu'est ce que c'est qu'on entend la la
ségo et la has et les goélands
c'est le cap une femelle chez les
oiseaux on recherche les les virus dans
le cloaque
on peut aussi les trouver dans la gorge
mais on les trouve plus régulièrement
dans le cloaque
on fait donc comme ça là un écouvillon
nage du cloaque pour recueillir les
matières fécales dans lesquels on peut
trouver ensuite le virus et il faut
recueillir une certaine quantité comme
ici une certaine quantité de matériel
qu'on met dans un milieu de conservation
et on va ensuite dans ce milieu cherché
à isoler le virus
la suite se passe en laboratoire les
virus en solutions sont injectés dans
des oeufs embryonnés où il se développe
un certain temps puis ils sont testés à
l'aide d'une réaction spécifique pour
savoir s'il s'agit de virus de la grippe
et si oui lesquelles
le but de ces recherches est de savoir
où les virus de la grippe humaine se
réfugie entre les périodes de neige
affectent l'homme on sait que les virus
revienne avec une périodicité variable
par exemple tous les 60 ans entre
pendant ces 60 ans ils sont quelque part
est l'une des hypothèse qui est à
l'étude
c'est de penser qu'ils sont réfugiés
dans une espèce animale quelconque on
peut espérer que le jour où un nouveau
virus de la grippe humaine se
manifestera
s'il vient d'une source animale eh bien
ça sera pas un inconnu pour nous il
n'est pas question de chercher à
éradiquer la grippe en tuant les oiseaux
c'est ça serait passé c'est pas du tout
possible et ce serait complètement
inefficace même si on essayait mais ce
qu'on peut espérer c'est avoir en main
tous les virus de la grippe possible qui
risque un jour de revenir chez l'homme
si on a une collection de sousse qui
sont déjà adaptés
on peut aller beaucoup plus vite pour
préparer avec ça et peut-être que le
prochain type de grippe humaine celui
qu'on attend pour une pandémie
éventuelle peut-être c'est un virus que
nous connaissons déjà sous le nom de
virus aviaire numéro 5 qui reviendra
chez la première interdiction en france
d'une course d'une course à voile la
croisière de l'edhec qui est l'école
d'hôtes supérieur des hautes études
pardon commerciales de lille n'a pas
reçu en effet l'autorisation d'organiser
son épreuve
cherbourg chabot cette même épreuve
s'est déroulée l'année dernière et
devait réunir dans quelques mois plus de
200 participants
le préfet maritime a justifié son
interdiction en évoquant une expérience
de certains équipages et les risques
encourus par la traversée de la manche
déjà encombré de multiples cargos et
pétroliers
cela dit c'est une décision que beaucoup
regretteront avant de vous donner les
résultats du loto et les pronostics de
pied à brest pour le tiercé je vous
laisse le temps d'aller chercher un
crayon en vous donnant maintenant la
météo aujourd'hui les régions
méditerranéennes ont bénéficié d'un
temps très ensoleillé sur les autres
régions le temps était frais et brumeux
il a plu sur l'alsace pour des mains
demain nous allons continuer à envier
les habitants de la région
méditerranéenne il fera en effet encore
beau là bas de nombreux nuages sur le
reste du pays
nuages plus abondants près de la manche
voici donc comme promis maintenant les
pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
tiercé qui se disputera demain à
vincennes dans le prix de l'orne
je vous laisse les découvrir le 14 le 15
le 7 le 13e 11 8 le 9
et puis le 12 les résultats du loto
maintenant pour gagner il fallait cocher
les six numéros qui vont s'inscrire et
qui s'inscrit sur votre récepteur si
vous en avez déjà 5 le 4 le 12 le 17 le
24 le 28 et le 30
le numéro complémentaire qui peut vous
servir et un numéro 32
voilà je referme maintenant ce journal
mais auparavant nous vous donnons les
principaux rendez-vous avec l'actualité
ce soir à 23h30 paul amar et puis demain
à 12h45 daniel bilalian pour antenne de
midi bonsoir à tous et à demain batteur